Can I look back over time and you say,
oh,
things are basically improved for the
greater lot of mankind.
There's always been a lot of problems
right now they're acute and we're more
interconnected and problems can infect
other parts of the world much more
easily.
But to date,
the lot of mankind,
I believe has generally gotten better.
There's been big setbacks.
Look at World War II,
look at Chairman Mao's great leap
forward,
the dark ages,
but in general,
like the stock market,
you might have a bull market in the bear
market.
I do think in the end,
uh,
you know,
problems can be dealt with and that
mankind will continue to improve on a
whole.